i had a feeling traffic would be
horrible and
parking as well tonight's matchup with
mexico
brought a lot of fans to allegiant
stadium for the concacaf
gold cup final as the usa came out
victorious
in a one to nothing win thank you so
much for joining us tonight at 11
o'clock
i'm sasha loftis the traffic and parking
to get to the game though caused a lot
of commotion
thousands of fans were frustrated
walking to the stadium in that
blistering heat today
madison kimbrough joins us live from
allegion stadium tonight with reaction
madison yeah the energy this afternoon
was thrilling
as both teams were being celebrated by
fans
here at allegiant stadium but i will say
that the lack of parking
took center stage as many had to shell
out hundreds just to find a spot
we're just trying to find a parking
place right now like kind of far even
though like everything's ticking
we're just going to walk there allegiant
stadium was a packed house with over 61
thousand fans
in attendance for the concacaf gold cup
final on sunday
it's not a mexico game unless you got
the tuba out here the sports event was
the largest soccer game attendance in
the history of nevada
and with it came some traffic woes to be
expected
but parking was no better real rough
it's real rough
can't even get no parking right now
shouldn't be like that at
all i had a feeling traffic would be
horrible and
parking as well fans tell us there was
not enough staff to handle the traffic
flow
and cars cutting in line ignoring the
detour signs
local businesses took advantage of the
lack of parking and offered spots of
their own
for a price i'm a psl ticket holder but
i guess i didn't get my tickets in time
so now we gotta park elsewhere and
everywhere else like 100 bucks 50 bucks
a crazy horse is 100
you want to come see the game you're
gonna do whatever it is overall almost
everyone we spoke to said come this fall
they hope the organization improves
closer to parking the more expensive it
gets i mean if you buy tickets you
should be able to not have to pay so
much
extra for the parking and additionally
i'm gonna still always come but
but the parking need to get better
though
the next big sporting event to take
place here at allegion
is you guessed it the pre-season opener
for the las vegas raiders versus the
seattle seahawks
that's going to be on saturday august
14th at 6 p.m
now coming up john will give you a full
highlight of the sports game coming up
in this broadcast reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now